one two three four five
[Applause]
with strikes spreading and talk of a
system on its knees is Britain's
reverence for its National Health
Service blocking much needed reform
Sajid Javid certainly thinks so the
conservative former Health secretary and
Finance Minister wrote recently the 75
year old model of the NHS is
unsustainable Javid suggested people
could pay for Consulting a family doctor
and praise Island system where patients
must pay around 81 to access the
equivalent of the UK's accident and
emergency departments a e and less
referred by their doctor now that's the
sort of idea most British politicians
run away from because it means scrapping
the doctrine that Healthcare should be
free at the point of need the Prime
Minister has distanced himself from the
comments but Rishi sunak did before
taking office talk about issuing fines
to NHS patients who Miss appointments he
then backtracked the opposition labor
parties also stepped into the debate
Shadow Health secretary Wes streeting
has suggested the growing waiting lists
could be tackled by the NHS sending more
patients to private hospitals
Louise Irvin a retired family doctor and
anti-privatization campaigner thinks
that's a bad idea isn't an infinite pool
of doctors and nurses and a lot of
doctors
in the private sector because they get
paid more and furthermore when something
goes wrong in the private sector the
patient is then you know red lighted
straight into a an NHS and E now if we
what we need is we need to build up our
NHS again Louise says she did see real
improvements in patient experience in
the 2000s under labor when annual
increases in NHS funding were higher
than they are now
since it was created spending on the NHS
has increased by an average 3.7 percent
per year in real terms but from 2010 to
2018 when the conservatives governed in
Coalition and then on their own annual
NHS funding growth slowed to 1.4 percent
it's rising more quickly now but an
aging population an increasing demand
for expensive treatments means nobody's
noticing if we look at the NHS compared
to other oecd countries we have fewer
doctors and nurses per head of
population we have fewer hospital beds
per head of population we have lower
levels of investment in things like
diagnostic equipment and all those
things are not about the way in which
this is the the NHS is organized and
funded that's about the the fundamental
decisions we made about the level of
that we want to spend on Health in this
country
so the challenge to the politicians is
this dealing with the crises hitting the
Health Service right now planning for
the long term and avoiding a two-tier
system Nadeem Barber Al Jazeera London